hi my name's sid i run an exterior
cleaning business in the uk and today
i'm going to be taking you through
cleaning a very mossy roof so this roof
hasn't been cleaned for the 28 years
that the homeowners have lived here
here i'm beginning to scrape the roof so
i'm trying to remove as much moss as
possible this is what i'll be doing for
the bulk of the day and this is the
hardest part of the job i have the tool
that i use it's basically a flat metal
blade uh angled to one side which means
i can get the edge of the tile which
usually carries a lot of the moss and
scrape the bulk surface of the tile at
the same time i use sort of a side to
side motion and it is very taxing on the
body so it takes a long time to build up
the endurance and strength to do it
so on this roof you'll see a lot of
brown and green this is the mars you'll
also see a lot of white spots people
think is bird droppings but this is
white lichen
moss is terrible for roofing and roof
materials especially in the uk as we get
a lot of damp weather over here so it
just tends to grow and fester more and
it'll grow in between the cracks of the
tiles now when you have hot weather turn
into cold weather the moss will freeze
and expand and then end up cracking the
roof tiles which can create holes leaks
and things like that in the roof so this
part of the job where i'm on the
scaffolding was the hardest so i used a
40 feet extendable pole with the scraper
attached on the end and i was almost at
max extension so the scraper itself is
quite heavy and the pole itself is quite
heavy so having that out a near
horizontal level for a couple of hours
is very difficult and as soon as this
was done i was relieved and happy to
move on to the next part
so what i'm cleaning here is a four
bedroom house it's got big flat concrete
tiles so these are some of the best
tiles to come across to clean the
surface area of them and because they're
completely flat it's very easy to get
the moss off you do not get roots better
than this
so it's rare that you'll actually get
away with using a broom to clean a roof
as usual the moss is very very stuck on
and it's typically just used for
cleaning up however on this job the moss
was coming off easy so in certain
sections it can just be easier just to
try and sweep off a majority and then
sort of fine-tune it with a scraper
so the typical cleaning chemicals that i
use in my roof cleaning work is a
chemical called a biocide
what this essentially will do is destroy
any of the organic growth left on the
roof and it has a residual cleaning
effect once i'm gone as well so there's
no rinse in it after you leave it on the
roof to fully dry and soak into the
tiles this will get anything that we
can't get to by scraping so anything
that's left in the gaps any sort of
really stubborn stains and marks that
are left on the tiles also will slowly
degrade so the brush that i'm using here
is a basic water fed pole that most
winter cleaners would use that's all you
need it's got four jets in it which will
fire out the chemical mixed with the
water onto the roof and the brush is
just used to agitate that chemical which
will help it foam up as you can see this
helps it stick to the roof more as it's
a natural surfactant so what i'm doing
here is i'm applying the biocide
solution to the roof now this is diluted
at 25 to 1 with water so for every one
liter of biocide i use 25 liters of
water to dilute it ensuring i'm covering
every square inch of this roof making
sure it's completely soaked in a lot of
mistakes people make is not putting
enough on and they're left with a very
patchy roof so it's really important to
get complete coverage and make sure all
of the tiny little gaps are completely
soaked
so if you don't fill all of the gaps on
the roof with the chemical then the moss
will regrow with a vengeance the
important part is making sure anything
organic on this roof is completely
absorbing this chemical so once the
biocide completely soaks and dries in
you would never even know it was on
there and your results will start to
come after a few weeks the main thing is
trusting in the chemical because it
definitely will do its job
so it's important to have your roof
cleaned because the build-up of moss
will over time damage the tiles on the
roof which can lead to cracks damp leak
all sorts of issues in your home that
you really don't want happening and if
the problem is not treated early enough
then it can lead to very expensive roof
repairs in the future as far as time
scale on how often should my roof be
cleaned
it is pretty much a one-time deal for
the majority of the process as long as
it's being kept on top of and in future
it would just be a light chemical
treatment just to keep anything at bay
so the first step is getting it done and
then it's a case of maintaining it